عقدت حكومة كوريا الجنوبية
اجتماعا طارئا يوم الاثنين بعد أن
أطلقت كوريا الشمالية
صاروخين باليستيين قصيري المدى مشتبه بهما ، وهذا هو
الاختبار الرابع الذي يتم إجراؤه في أقل من
ثلاثة أسابيع وهو معدل إطلاق مرتفع بشكل غير عادي ،
لذا دعونا نلقي
نظرة على ما يجري  في غضون 90 ثانية ،
زعمت وسائل الإعلام الرسمية في كوريا الشمالية أنه
تم بنجاح اختبار صاروخ تفوق سرعته سرعة الصوت
في
يناير و 11 يناير ،
كما قالوا إن صاروخين باليستيين
يُفترض أنهما قصير المدى تم
اختبارهما يوم الجمعة الماضي
في 14 يناير ثم كما ذكرنا
آخر.  بعد يوم واحد فقط من ثلاثة
أيام ، لا يقتصر الأمر على التردد ولكن أيضًا
توقيت عمليات الإطلاق هذه في شهر يناير ،
وهو أمر غير معتاد ، حيث تحتفظ الدولة في كثير من الأحيان
بمثل هذه الاختبارات للاحتفال
بالأحداث المهمة سياسياً أو ردًا على
التدريبات العسكرية الكورية الجنوبية ، فلماذا
يحدث هذا
في بيان صدر مؤخرًا
ودافع المتحدث الذي نقلته وسائل إعلام رسمية عن
حق البلاد في تعزيز أسلحتها قائلا إن الأمر حدث
مؤخرا  كان نشر الأسلحة من النوع الجديد مجرد
جزء من جهوده لتحديث
قدرات الدفاع الوطني ، لذا من
يرى كوريا الشمالية على أنها أكبر عدو لها ،
فإن الولايات المتحدة
وفقًا لبيان أدلى به
قبل تولي بايدن منصبه ، لتعزيز
دفاعها الوطني ليس فقط
أولوية دولية ولكن  وهو أيضًا أمر
محلي للزعيم كيم جونغ أون في
وقت تواجه فيه البلاد
نقصًا في الغذاء ، وتعزل نفسها إلى حد
كبير عن بقية
العالم أثناء الوباء ، والآن
يحظر مجلس الأمن التابع للأمم المتحدة
كوريا الشمالية من الأسلحة البالستية والنووية.
لم تختبر كوريا الشمالية صواريخها
الباليستية طويلة المدى
أو الأسلحة النووية منذ عام 2017.
ولكن بعد توقف محادثات نزع السلاح النووي
في عام 2019 ، بدأت في اختبار مجموعة
من تصميمات الصواريخ الباليستية الجديدة قصيرة المدى ،
وقد أثارت الاختبارات الأخيرة نداءً
من المجتمع الدولي
وقد دعا الحوار مع الولايات المتحدة لإعادة بدء البيت الأبيض لإجراء محادثات أثناء
أ  أيضًا الرد بمزيد من العقوبات ، وهو
رد تصفه كوريا الشمالية بأنه
سياسة عزل وخانقة ،
وطالما ظلت الصين الحليف الوثيق لكوريا الشمالية
صامتة بشأن إطلاق الصواريخ ،
فليس هناك حافز كبير لكوريا الشمالية
للتوقف عن استعراض تلك العضلات الباليستية.